let's go next to scipio
from california scipio from california
you're on the air
scipio in california you're on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
hey this is so cool i'm a long time
listener but first time caller thank you
um i wanted to ask uh we're like a year
into coven 19 impacting the us
and there's still people that just won't
take the guidelines seriously at all
like
just this week i had to go inside an
office and i didn't see one person
wearing a mask and right i i don't
like know at this point like what can
you do
to try and convince those people it's as
serious as it is because i try to share
information
and citations with friends and family
and on my social media but it just seems
like i'm
screaming into the void so i just wanted
to get your thoughts sadly at this point
at this point i don't know that there is
much to do and you know unfortunately
let me let me back up fortunately cases
are going down
vaccination is increasing and and
hopefully over the next
four to six months we are going to see a
dramatic change to the circumstances
um coronavirus may become seasonal sort
of like the flu
uh whatever things are going to improve
most of those people who have not been
paying attention to the guidelines all
along
they may be responsible for the deaths
of others most of them of course will
survive
and they will be re they will see their
actions reinforced because they'll say
look we got through it i never wore a
mask i did whatever the hell i wanted if
i got it it wasn't that bad
for me and unfortunately we're sort of
at the point where
i think they're beyond reach and they
will benefit from vaccination just as
much as everybody who's been well
behaved will benefit
it will reinforce their belief that it
wasn't that bad
ever and i don't know there's much that
we can do about it
yeah that's unfortunately the conclusion
yeah
i've sort of arrived at as well but uh
yeah i'm glad it's we're at least seeing
the light at the end of the tunnel
um now are are the bosses not enforcing
is there not a mask policy or is there
one but it's not enforced
um at the places that i've been to
like the person who's sort of running
the office like they've been there and
they've
also been uh without a mask oh i said
and like yeah i've seen it where the
people who would be in charge of
whatever that
context is like they're also not wearing
a mask so it's
it's like a work culture thing got it
got it got it yeah i mean uh
it's it's happening in many parts of the
country more and some than others and
eventually they're all going to get
bailed the ones that survive
which of course statistically will be
most of them will will sort of be bailed
out by vaccines
yeah yeah i didn't know if you uh i know
a lot of people have been talking about
the
um snowstorm but i don't know if you saw
the bloomberg
interviewed dan woodfin he's a senior
director for electrical
reliability council of texas and he even
came out and said like
this nonsense about wind turbines is
just that it's nonsense and he
sort of breaks down like how much energy
it makes up and how it doesn't make
sense that
people are blaming like wind turbines
and clean energy for what's going on
i didn't see that but certainly i've
read similar analyses and it's very
clear that the problem here is not wind
turbines yeah
yeah anyways thanks for taking my call
david all right thanks very much there's
scipio
from california great to hear from you
um
let's see where are we going to go next
there's a lot of very
interesting people wanting to get on
let's go to
darren from the united kingdom darren
from the uk you're on the air
david yes great program thank you
so um i have a lighthearted question for
you all right so
when netflix make insurrection the tv
show
um who would you cast as uh trump
mcconnell
and giuliani oh wow i have no idea
trump mcconnell and julie i don't know i
mean maybe trump it would be alec
baldwin i think the the real question is
who will cast who will be cast as me and
um i think i would like it to be joseph
gordon levitt if i'm totally honest with
you
cool lovely show keep the faith
okay thank you very much a very very
powerful question if anybody knows
joseph gordon lovett let's see if we can
make that happen i would like it uh
if he portrayed me that would be really
good